Robinson Los Angeles hey Robin how are
you sure what's up well I sold the
lighthouse and he bought a smaller house
and I talked to my CPA and also my
financial planner about the best way to
handle the dollars that were coming in
from the larger house to pay off the
smaller house if that's what you want to
do on your portfolio maybe what you
should do is put the money in the
portfolio continue to service the
mortgage and you know have a few percent
left over after that but I want to but
something's bothering you about it if
the house was paid for yeah and you met
with your financial planner he said I
want you to go get a mortgage so that
you can invest more with me so you can
make the spread would you do that no
what's the difference
hello what's the difference what's the
nerds and so you would pay off this
mortgage today you know why because when
I asked you that in Reverse rather than
the way you're asking me about it in
other words we're actually like the
house is paid off would you go borrow on
it or should you pay it off it's the
same math exactly but when I ask it in
reverse it causes you to think not only
with your mind where you do math but
with your heart where you do risk your
financial planner and your CPA are using
a naive primitive financial formula that
is inaccurate because it leaves out risk
and you and I having common sense know
that their mortgages even though it's a
small mortgage has a certain amount of
risk associated with it and they have
not mathematically adjusted for that
risk and so I'm of the opinion that the
borrower is slave to the lender 100% of
the time not part of the time and I've
done detailed research here at Ramsey
solutions and we found that 100% of the
foreclosures occur on a home with a
mortgage there's risk associated with
this and so I don't bar I don't borrow
money to invest and not paying off debt
in order to keep investments is exactly
the same equation so I disagree
passionately with the primitive naive
horrible financial formula that your
financial planner and CPA are using I
would pay off this mortgage in 20
seconds hope that helps because I don't
wanna be unclear this is the Dave Ramsey
show